[Music]  yo do you have any lunch plans  yeah actually I was thinking about  getting some fast food fast food this is  the greatest meal I've ever had this is  luxury cheap fast and delicious there  are literally no negatives too fast the  zero negatives I'm gonna be so  productive after this this is the  greatest decision we've ever heard I am  a monster I regret everything it was you  you suggested we sorry I'm sorry what  maybe 60,000 calories  why would you let me do this no one can  know about this that was the worst juice  of five dollars over I will never do you  know do you have any dinner plans yeah  actually I was thinking about getting  some  [Music]